all right we got callers suggestions for
Andrew them limpets are on the horizon
we got one of the best callers questions
that I've heard yet has hit the hotline
happy and excited to share that sucker
and then drop that lint into your trap
it's only Thursday so what
so why we've done Thursday before we got
this again it's Thursday January 11th
this past weekend there we go man it's
like taking your shoes off at your
cousin's house baby that's what I feel
like we miss his like taking your shoes
and your socks off gonna let your cousin
[Music]
get a hit of your stank let's have some
fun while we all die yeah and that is
Spencer Jacob grab and and Spencer Jacob
for those of you guys who don't know he
hit me up okay I don't even remember
when it could have been a year ago and
said hey I feel like this is something
you could use he might be able to help
your podcast and I've met him in person
you have long hair I mean that boy has
long hair you know in long hair is
dangerous to me because say you're
hanging out of a window you don't think
anybody could get you with a fade nobody
can really wrangle you but you're
hanging out of a window and you got that
long hair somebody could jump up get you
snatch on to you you know you could get
your hair cut in a [ __ ] blender
you're trying to make a smoothie next
thing you know you're making yourself
next thing you know boy you next thing
you know frickin to one of your ears and
cheeks ends up in a big sippy cup it's
just that and that's the dangers I feel
like I'm having that long hair so
sometimes when I do see people with
really long hair you know I'll say a
soft prayer for them in my head or
somewhere in the back of my head you
know that's something that happens with
me sometimes small prayers will go off
in in the back in the back of my head
good to be here man welcome to this past
weekend and it's the Thursday edition
and I am excited to be here with you
guys thank you all for joining me I'm
just checking my levels here and making
sure that we're all good and that is
that I got to guest host today I'll
fight her in the kid you know and it was
fun I got to go in there Brendan Schaub
was in there they got that beautiful uh
they have a beautiful Korean gentleman
in there named Qin Yun and he is I mean
he's Korean you know and he is um in
Koreans they seem very you know it seem
like they have secrets in them and I've
always felt that someone's about a lot
of Asian people and this this can be me
being judgmental but this is also just
me exploring my thoughts here is that
you know when you see an Asian you kind
of from me I get a sense of wonderment
you know I got a sense of like Oh
peacefulness staring at two Asians or
three Asians it's almost like meditating
for for a minute it's almost just as
effective when you see the docile
Necedah sylheti that the heavens and
that the lord have packaged in you know
to a korean or to a Laotian you see them
just oh man it's um it's pretty
remarkable you know it's pretty
remarkable sometimes to see to see an
Asian and a feel that inquisitiveness
about what's going on in there you know
and I've always wondered what it would
be like to be Asian and what it feels
like and I actually got to talk to him
about that a little bit and it was
pretty cool to get some of his take on
they're over at the fighter and the kid
and I spend time at Brendan Schaub II
said he's sick he said he have a little
bit of something I don't know what it is
something got him something got up in
his system you know he wears a lot of
fancy clothes and different types of
fancy wool on his body if you guys don't
know who this man is his name is Brendan
Schaub
and he is a he was a fighter you know
and he was one of those men that would
get into those cages and those dirty
cages because some of them look dirty if
you look at him on maybe the television
must might I might be watching and only
720p or something but some of them cages
look like they don't really dust all the
bars and everything on him and these men
get in there and they're fighting and
you know and some of them look like they
have ear infections and all kinds of
[ __ ] and they're tatted up and they're
in there just beating the damn bile out
of each other's [ __ ] and he was one
of those guys and he did he didn't die
or anything and he's you know mentally
he is he's alert you know and he's I
don't know if he I mean he might have to
wake up every day and hit those smelling
salts just to get his day go and I don't
know but he seems active and quaffed
he's very you know he's coming in a
little bit French if you look at him
he's very quaffed up you know we have
special types of gels and lotions on his
ears and everything his whole skin and
everything you know it's almost like
you know like something like they just
dip him in some type of a fancy tub of
of damn [ __ ] Guatemalan space
chemicals or something in the morning
and it just leaves him fresh you know it
looks like he's the kind of dude that
kind of washes his ass with coconut
water you know he's a little bit fancy
like that but he was a fighter so
there's these two elements to him he's
you know coming in kind of France kind
of Frank kind of French and then he also
has this element where you know he's
been through the battles of men but he
wears a lot of fancy different types of
wool and [ __ ] you know fancy attire
could be alpaca could be Mogadishu you
know I'm not sure what types of furs and
stuff he wears but he you know he has a
lot of fancy footwear and he might you
know he might have cufflinks at his
house you know somewhere in his closet
he might have a shelf that's starting to
come out of the wall a little bit cuz it
have so many cuff links on it heavy cuff
links because he has strong arms too he
could probably hold up some heavy
cufflinks but he's you know he's um he
is one of he's one half of the duo
called the fighter and the kid and it
was nice to be in there and Brian is his
partner and their non-central partners
they're just work work partners
associates and friends and their podcast
is called the fighter in the kid if you
haven't got to check it out
I recommend that you do check it out and
but Brian couldn't be there today
because Brian is he's an actor and I've
known Bryan Callen is his name and I've
known him since I came into town and he
was always like this guy that I've
really looked up to his uh he just has a
charisma you know he has a spark in his
eyes he has two sparks one in each eye
and it's like trying to think of what it
feels like when you're around him it's
almost like he has this grin and stuff
like he's up to no good and he probably
is up to no good
but he's also at the same time up to
good and that's the vibe that I've
always got
but I've always admired him as a
performer and I remember seeing him on
Entourage the television program and
I've always admired seeing him and and
but anyway he wasn't he couldn't be in
there today cuz something happened to
him and so I was able to go in there and
be a guest associate in there today
and it was fun we had a nice time and
that's one thing that's been like a
blessing I guess in this podcast
universe is that you just get to have
conversations with people you know for
so long in my life out here in Los
Angeles and even probably just in my
regular life there was something I
couldn't conversate very well I couldn't
sit there and listen to someone I
couldn't sometimes I couldn't hear
people you know really just was so just
stuck inside of my head that I couldn't
hear I mean I could hear him I could
hear the sounds and I knew what they
were saying but I couldn't ever
internalize or or really be involved in
the conversation and it's been nice with
some of these podcasts just sit in a
room for a while with another man
and nobody's doing cocaine or nobody's
trying to touch each other's private or
you know you know pretend the lights
went out so they could you know try and
touch each other's underarms or anything
like that and just enjoy enjoy their
company and also not feel that pressure
because out here in Los Angeles there's
a lot of there's a lot of pressure on
straight men to let men out there you
know to turn around you know to get into
the internet what you know to you know
just just throw your dick out into them
into the end of the it's a lot of
pressure out here I don't want to say
it's gay pressure but you get out here
in some of these environments and you
know there will be a dude trying to
trick you into just throwing your dick
up in the air to see who will catch it
and it's like I know who will try and
catch it you will you will brother and
so a lot of times you know a lot of gay
men will be like well you know this
fellas try
gay men a lot of times would be like you
know I didn't choose to be gay it's an
it's part of nature and I believe that a
hundred percent you know I think it's I
think it is it's very to me to me it
seems narrow to believe that people who
are gay don't want to that they chose
that now I think these days we are
getting into more times where people are
choosing whatever they want whatever
they feel like that evening you know if
they want a little bit of that you know
a little bit of that fricking brown-eyed
girl then they might find another man
you know if they want that Hershey you
know that little Hershey peephole they
might find another man for their night
but internally you know I think men who
are gay are born that way and and so you
have a lot of men out here will be like
well I didn't choose to be this way you
know this is not choices and mother
nature this is the way I am and that's
that's a now respect that that's that's
to them that's the who they are but then
it's wild because you'll be at a bar and
you'll have a gay gentleman trying to
get you to pretend to be gay and I'm
like whoa whoa whoa buddy bear I'm not
gay and it would be like well how do you
know because dude when I look deep into
your eyes Deuter will you look deep into
my eyes I want to defend myself that's
why but it's crazy sometimes you a lot
of gay dudes there the gay dudes are
keen because there's still dudes they
still gonna try to get what they want to
get you know they're still gonna try to
maneuver and block and in Parian you
know assault and you know and not
assault you know but just you know take
action defense action defense to try to
catch that hit a seed you know to try to
get another man to spray out and so it's
you got to be where out here of me
because that's a the first-rate men in
LA that's the pressure circle comes
around when they when the gentlemen show
up and they're fancy and they want to be
fancy with you but you don't want to you
know I remember they had um I had a
manager that set me up with uh and I
think I've talked about this bride a
manager who set me up with a what was it
uh agent and this gentleman trying to
take me out to the club and I'm thinking
I'm young I'm new in town
you know I still have my hair still had
all of his full natural color from God
that straight of Roy G bib that he
dropped into my skull was still fully
evident in my mane and this man you know
I remember him you know he's trying to
be fancy in the club and get me drinks
getting me tall drinks drinks that have
two drinks in one drink double drinks
and I'm just you know kind of you know
I'm wise I'm keen but I'm also you know
I'm wanting to make it and Holly you
know I got those kind of desires and
thoughts in my head and this man he had
a convertible car and so you know he's
got me trying you know he's driving me
home and he's got that keep putting that
convertible top saying he likes how my
hair seems wild you know and he put his
hand over on my leg and kind of squeezed
on my leg a little as you know like when
he made a joke almost like a dad with a
kid you know you're like if you make a
funny joke and you squeeze you know you
squeeze your child's thigh a little bit
or something and that's and that's safe
area if it's you and your child you know
and that's just comfortable hand
activity but this fella you had me
feeling uncomfortable but that's
sometimes something have to worry about
out here as a straight man and Terry
Crews actually came out about it you
know they have a lot of this myth uh you
know the me to campaign going on or not
campaign but people sharing the the the
experiences that have happened to them
and some horrid experiences but then you
also got experiences coming out now like
this
dude asked me out once what a piece of
[ __ ] like we'll come on what's he
supposed to do he's just trying to be a
man he's just trying to be a man but as
a straight man out here in Los Angeles
that's where it comes around for you a
lot of times is is gay men out here
trying to be wild and no disrespect to
game in at all you know of a couple of I
have one of my best friends Matthew Cole
Weiss is a gay gentleman and he and I
love him to death man you know I know
that he's had a ton of struggles one of
the same places that he and I struggle
is with depression and that's one of the
things that made us be friends in the
first place I mean I met he had a roller
skating party this dude this girl I knew
and she was a little thick kind of you
know round in the chest you know no real
tits but a lot of [ __ ] sternum
sometimes that sternum stacks up so much
in the front it's just nipples on bone
out there and she had that you know not
even a B C's or DS just you know just a
couple of just just [ __ ] nipples
holding their own
you know rooted and bone and she took me
to a party and it was his birthday party
and there was men out there everybody
was rollerskating and years later he'd
be like well how did you know that I was
gay when he you know because I think you
know it seems like when you're a gay man
and we'll have one of as soon as we can
get some guests in here we're gonna
start getting into some questions and
really been able to talk to people that
are different than me so that I can you
know have some experiences with these
people and learn more about what it's
like to really live in somebody else's
shoes but he said well how did you know
his guess at man well you know I had an
inkling you know I'm no [ __ ] MacGyver
but I had an inkling when you was having
a rollerskating birthday party at the
age of 26 that would you know that was a
[ __ ] you know that was a that was a
dime in the tip jar right there but yeah
that's one thing you got to worry about
here's a straight
is the other man coming around and it's
big now it's a sexual harassment and
with all these allegations and
everything out there does make me wonder
it makes me it makes me think back on
some of my own past you know to my own
choices and I've never been violent with
women you know I had well I had an
instance when I was in high school when
I got extremely drunk at a party and I
blacked out I don't remember this and
when I blacked out if I was at a party I
like to try and find the nicest car at
the party and if the keys went I like to
take that [ __ ] for a spin you know cuz
I got the dark hearts living down inside
of me I got the gesture of death down
there juggling juggling you know
juggling oranges in my soul and he will
when I'm out but not when I shut down up
top in the brainstem because of that
liquor he will take me for a ride you
know he'll go out there and find the
nicest car and take that [ __ ] around
the block you know because he wants to
endanger me and I remember being at this
party and next thing I know my buddy
you know he was like kind of a defense
kind of boy in our town and he had a
little bit of that D s that down
syndrome
and I actually talked about this today
on on Brendan Schaub and the fighter and
the kid my buddy heard that you know
that I had gotten physical with this
girl at this party you know and and he
say you know you hit you hit this girl
you hit this girl you know and I have
look I have no recollection of this at
all am I saying that I'm one responsible
for it but I mean when I saw her the
next day she didn't have you know it
wasn't like I had she said you pushed me
down and uh and that hurt man it hurt to
know that if I wasn't in control of
myself that that the actions that could
come out of me but also what hurt was
the dude that put me in the dude that
came in a accosted me about it when he
heard about it he put me in that [ __ ]
in a chokehold and I don't have you ever
been enough in a chokehold of a fella
but has um downs syndrome or Down
syndrome I don't know what they're
calling it these days but he [ __ ] put
me in net that hit our boy in that hard
scarf he called you know he put that
[ __ ] hard scarf on me and I couldn't
man but uh but anyhow you know I'm
rambling but I want to get into some of
the calls that have come in you know but
it is it when you hear about these
sexual allegations in this and that it
does make you start to think in your own
life where there are times when I was
out of line you know were there times
when a girl wanted to leave my place and
I was you know being wild and sometimes
that's not a problem sometimes that's
normal chain of command that's normal
what's going on
as a man behavior I'm not gonna you know
part of man is that you know that that
samba you know you come you come close
I'll back up you back up I'll come close
and on and on and on and on until
somebody's you know skeet now or you
know sloshing out of themselves and
that's part of the party but it's when
you know you it makes it just makes me
think and that's okay these times are
okay they make us think but every
interesting you know when some of these
allegations come out I would also like
to see how many I know there's female
predators out there as well you know
there's some shady babies out here
there's some shady babies out here and
the mangroves you know what I'm saying
and there's some ladies out here who can
you know who got you know got women out
there you know you know who's feeding
them soup out of there for jeans and all
of that doing all kinds of crazy stuff
and they got women out there who were
you know a lot of women have probably
approached a lot of these men and tried
to [ __ ] their way up and I think that's
that missing element that needs to also
be shared so that we can see that the
cycle because a lot of times we've you
know everybody wants to complete you
know 70 percent of the equation but they
don't want to put in that 30 percent
that doesn't tell their story fully or
that won't that doesn't fill in the
whole realm
you know and I think this is you we got
to start filling in the whole realm and
being honest about what's going on
across the board but this episode you
know we usually on Thursday we do some
follow-up you know we had a call that
came in on the Monday morning episode
and this is what it was and I'm gonna
I'm gonna play with that for you right
now and then we're gonna get into
somebody you guys as responses you guys
hit the hotline with some great
responses the hotline is nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three if you
have a thought about the podcast a
question if you have a fear a concern
you can share your name you cannot share
your name just know that if you hit the
hotline that we may then use that call
on the show just once you guys to know
that but anybody out there that needs it
needs help need some group think you
know I'm happy to share any suggestions
that I have I don't have all the answers
I don't have actually [ __ ] any of the
answers dude I'm 37 years old boy you
know and I'm uh I'm and I'm and I'm out
here driving this struggle bus son all
aboard here we go this was the call that
came in from Andrew Monday all right
here we go
my name is Andrew from Prince Edward
Island Canada I want to address a dark
arts
my wife is overweight I was overweight
we both agreed on it I've lost the
weight and she hasn't and there's no way
for me to bring it up without being the
[ __ ] or the emotional abuse of men
but I'm just not attracted to her and I
don't want to [ __ ] her so I do turn to
porn on us I don't know I'm just
attracted to a certain thing and she was
it and now she's not and I don't know
how to tell her that she's got to get
back to that Wow and that was the call
and that was heavy and ruin we got some
calls that came in for you man I don't
want to get into those I want to get
into those also want to let you guys
know that then I'm gonna be performing I
want you to let you know I'm performing
this weekend January 11th through the
14th at the Brea improv January 8th
through 18th through 20th I'm at the new
comedy club in Jacksonville Florida
February 8th through 11th I'm at Harveys
in Portland Oregon and that's at Pacific
Northwest up
where people are [ __ ] drinking pine
tree juice and uh people are putting you
know wearing flannel hats and [ __ ] and
you know rolling their babies and uh in
in fish tears and all of that [ __ ]
February 16th through the 18th I'll be
in La Jolla California at the Comedy
Store
February 22nd through the 24th Indio
California fantasy Springs casino and
also in March I'll be in Tacoma March
22nd and 23rd I believe and that oh no
March 15th 16th and 17th I'll be at
Tacoma and Spokane at Spokane on the
17th and those will be going up on theof
on calm slash tour okay Andrew we had
that call come in and I want to I want
to get some of you guys's responses for
Andrew I hope you I hope you're
listening Andrew if you are if you're
not Andrew and you're somebody that has
had a similar circumstance which man I
think we can all you know relate in the
way that we've wanted our spouse or
someone we care about to be different
and here's some some responses here we
go hey the guy the guy I think his
name's Andrew you're unhappy with your
chick cuz the way she looks you take a
long hard look and think about what
you're doing and I'm gonna tell you what
not to do because I was in that position
this feels like it's gonna be good
let go at no point at no point do you
tell her it's because of her [ __ ]
wait
find another avenue because I did that
to my ex-wife and it crushed her well
women are more sensitive than we are
so you're right not to let her know
marriage to them means for better for
worse for real she's at her worse you
loved her for better now where yet wow
man I appreciate that call man sorry
about that's my email and I really put
that's a good that's a good call and
that's for real you know yeah it's like
who do we
I've been because I know I've been a
piece of [ __ ] and people have still
loved me and you know what's the wildest
is that's when you really learn who
loves you that's when you really learn
who loves you you know when I'm you know
in the gym and I got the ABS going and
I'm feeling great about myself and I got
my medication the milligrams are on
point you know and I'm feeling you know
vibrant and I got a new shirt
yeah oh it's easy for ya it's whoo yeah
everybody loves me then you know but
when I haven't brushed my teeth in three
days because I'm not feeling good you
know and I'm wearing this shirt that's
wrinkled because you know I didn't feel
like I put it in the dryer two days ago
but then I got depressed and felon a
poor didn't you know take all my
responsibilities and stay on top of my
game you know and I'm wearing the same
pants and belt because my belts [ __ ]
broken and I tied it and I've been
jerking off so much I'm too weak to even
untie that belt off of me around my
waist so I got the same pants on because
I ain't got enough strength in my arms
because I'm skeeted out my Energy's all
sprayed out of my wiener
then what when somebody still loves you
then you know and that's a good call man
I appreciate you saying that cuz that
that makes me think you know I needed to
hear that you know cuz I I certainly
have somebody you know in my life who's
loved me and uh you know at some of my
toughest moments you know in moments
where I felt like I was alone or moments
where moments where I probably would
have been had some fear or business you
know I'll be real been scared you know
going into a surgery or going into you
know going into a tough day and they
called or they checked in you know so
that's a you know that's a good way to
frame it up now Andrea I'm not trying to
point any fingers of you or blame you we
don't know your situation exactly but
but that's a good call and that's a good
way to think and that
and those things do sit heavier with
women you know with men is different
because women they know once they have a
baby - you know their bodies all that
you know they start rubik's cube n' and
next thing you know what you know half
their stomach is down but on their
thighs and everything changes you know
and that's just part of god's plan out
here we've got another call that came in
and this one this one let's let's hear
it i have not heard any of these calls
yet but i do know in the notation here
it says that this is from david who's a
marriage and family therapist calling in
for andrew here we go this is david
calling in response to Andrews question
on your last episode what I want you
think about first say thank you thank
you for calling David onward and is your
wife she don't want to be fat and
overweight and by you losing the weight
guess what that does that makes her feel
more shitty and more insecure trust me
every guy out there if you don't like
your body like the way you look think
about the normal woman time data by a
hundred and that's how they think about
their body and in her mind because you
lost the weight is gonna make it harder
for her right one other thing I want you
to understand is that being real is how
you're gonna connect with them so being
vulnerable is very valuable you got to
be vulnerable to even be available to
connect with her and in pornography is
an intimacy issue dude think about this
you're more likely to look at porn when
you don't have a connection with their
self family's friends you're not
connected with your job if you're not
connect to your wife you're definitely
more likely to look at pornography so
those are all just information so like
that but I know you want to be a
positive influence for your wife I know
you don't want a divorce man you pull
her aside and you sell her you tell her
to remember you got to be vulnerable as
her first you can't just be like hey you
got to do better you got to lose weight
all that criticism aching work tell her
baby I know I've made some comments
about your weight I criticize you in the
past and I'm sorry give her compliments
throughout the day when you see her
making little choices like you know just
incest and oh yeah you could eat better
just say hey you know babe like that's
cool she chose that you didn't have to
do that and there you go and I know I
let that's that call play long but that
gentleman talks fast you know and that
guy sounds pretty smart and he talked
pretty quick you know in any man that
can put that many words together
successfully in a row without and it
sounded like you even use the correct
punctuation so at that point you let a
man
go you know that's like when somebody
you know they're gonna train's coming by
and you know you want to touch one of
the windows on it man [ __ ] that dude you
touch the window on a Prius when it's
going by you don't [ __ ] touch the
window on a train and that man uh that
man was on a train but I appreciate that
that's um got some good insight you know
it's just a little more insight for you
there we got another call that came in
right here
and then guys we got one of the best
caller questions I've had come in I just
know it from the sub line and I'm just
ecstatic bro so let's let's keep this
vibe going here here we go what's going
on Theo this is uh Nathan from New
Hampshire thank you for calling Nathan
from New Hampshire and one of my good
friends Mike bug is from over in New
Hampshire and and that's a beautiful
state that I've never been to but that
my luggage got lost one time on
Southwest Airlines and my luggage went
to New Hampshire so a lot of my clothes
that I'll wear if you see me sometimes
you might look at him and be like oh
he's been in New Hampshire but that's
just an illusion because my clothes have
been on work Colin in in regards to
Andrew and his issues with his wife and
their issue losing weight together I
guess my first suggestion to him would
be try to get his wife to go with him to
the gym you know try to persuade her say
I don't want to go to the gym by myself
it'll be a lot easier if we go together
we can motivate each other use that type
of tactic or you can also use the whole
new year's resolution thing I mean I
think it's perfect timing for that you
know say hey why don't one of your new
year's resolutions be to go to the gym
more often and uh get uh make that deal
happen that we had together because it
sounds like he completed his into the
bargain
and she didn't yeah that's a good
thought that's a good thought right
there you know the the damn spin of the
earth you know it went around the moon
or whatever however it works up there
364 times to give you that excuse right
about now didn't it mr. Andrew so you
have that galactic excuse on the horizon
and that's you know that's
[ __ ] if this [ __ ] happens in May boy you
should out of luck
but the shit's happening right now here
we go man we got another caller that
came in but I you know that's you know
oh it's tough man it's a tough situation
that you're in and it's tough also
because of the influences that are out
there today it's like even if you're not
looking at pornography even if you're
not doing that [ __ ] if I look through my
Instagram feed say I'll wake up in the
morning right say you're with your girl
or say you're with your girl you wake up
in the morning she's at her place you
know y'all gonna meet for breakfast you
you know you out there you hit the
toilet you know you letting your body do
that blow out
you know you changing you [ __ ] all
and and you look at your Instagram feed
you've seen you're just looking at
regular pictures you're not even looking
at anything nasty or any you know any
titty work or anything like that or even
any pictures of women by the beach
or anything you're just looking at
regular stuff now going through the feed
you're gonna see nine or eleven pictures
of chicks hot chicks probably attractive
women are women trying to look their
most attractive and doing it
successfully so before you even meet
your lady before you even meet your lady
for breakfast you've already seen nine
or 11 good-looking chicks
you've already been stimulated because
here's the thing you might look at
something you don't think anything your
brain think something your brain is way
our brains are way more powerful than we
are out here so next thing you know you
see your lady you've already been
stimulated nine or eleven times by hot
women and if some of those women are in
sensual positions or you know [ __ ]
you know picking an apple out of a tree
with the [ __ ] with their ass or
whatever you know some of these women
are doing on the internet and you know
jumping up in the air [ __ ] you know
showing their [ __ ] to the moon or
whatever they're doing you um
if you see that you're stimulated before
you even see your woman so what I'm
saying is there's so much stimulation
out there that we don't even know that's
chipping away at our libidos before we
even see our lady so it's front lines
out there sorry that's an alarm right
there reminded me to not think about
myself you know I'm [ __ ] up when I got
that thing on there but yeah so look the
stimulation is out there and we're
fighting it and that's uh that's a but
that's a good that's a really good point
that you gave in there you know Nathan
with that call right there that's a
really good point that you that you gave
and I'm gonna play the end of that one
more time I want to go to the gym by
myself it'll be a lot easier if we go
together we can motivate each other
there you go
because the thing is if sometimes you
have to do it together it's not like you
do it and I'll do it let's do it at the
same time that doesn't always work
because if you get it done then at a
certain point I wonder our Andrew if you
were even for the second half of your
training were you even training out of
resentment like was resentment fueling
you because that would be fueling me if
I make a deal with my lady and she's not
doing it I'm still doing it then I'm
going to the gym and I'm showing up and
a half that second you know them last
[ __ ] 40 humps with those kettlebells
are out of resentment and I'm coming
back to the house on my shirt off I'm
spraying extra [ __ ] you know rose
water on my chest in the car and [ __ ]
for I go in the house so I'm looking
flexy when I walk in and at that point
I'm Rui I'm riding on you know what's
what's driving me is not healthy and I'm
not accusing you with that I'm just
saying that would be me that would be me
if I was in your shoes that's that's
what would have been happening to me we
got a beautiful lady that called in here
just as female caller that's all I know
we're hearing this together for the
first time here we go
hi yeah I have some advice for your
caller Andrew yeah thank you for calling
let's hear it I would say to Andrew
it's him and his wife mindfuck ever my
significant other and I we don't really
you know defect that much but our mind
bugs every day
he's just my ride-or-die he's the kind
of person that if I'm feeling down he'll
do anything in the world to make it
better and you know that's what I need
in the partner out of life and I don't
know for Andrew it's not the truth for
his life so if he has issues in that
department that might be what's causing
a lot of the regret or resentment on
choices why should I stay focus on what
really matters unless those people that
will be there for you yep and I didn't
mean to cut you off hey let's hear the
end of that those people that will be
there for you no matter what sorry the
call ends right there and that lady's
saying well how about mine [ __ ] you
know that that's more important than
being out there in the sensual streets
that getting your minds to [ __ ] you
know reach across the room and tangle up
next to each other you know letting your
thoughts mix and letting your words mix
and sharing ideas and being sentimental
and sensual that way and not even ideas
like aw let's touch and let's [ __ ]
you know squeeze each other's titty meat
and [ __ ] like that she just means
regular conversation I'm assuming she
just means you know talking
communicating and I noticed that too man
I you know this girl I was talking to
and I've been talking to and you know
and when I get that you know like I need
if things get too complacent in the
communication that can be scary when you
just fall into these comfortable
patterns it can be awesome because it's
comfortable but at the same time it's it
it loses the allure kind of dies you
know some of the novelty wears off and
even in conversation and so you have to
[ __ ] man huh and I'm just realizing now
I don't see how some of you guys do it I
don't see I don't even see how you do
any I mean I don't see how I don't see
how some of these guys do it and stay in
these relationships aren't able to do it
I commend you man I commend you fellows
if you're out there if you're out there
and you stay in you holding the line you
know you out there done kirkin foot
ass you know for that wife for that
family you out there done kirkin cuz
[ __ ] man I've thrown in the white I've
raised the white flag dude many at times
and not even when they when the going
got tough [ __ ] I've brought the white
flag to the first date you know but I
don't want to always be that way and I
don't plan to always be that way but but
sometimes uh you know where we are where
we are until we take action and then we
can end up where we want to be and
that's why I'm hopefully trying to do
here we go now Andrew this call says
Andrew added more info Andrew called and
added more info now some of you guys
know we got the assistant Chris Perez a
Latino gentleman and and we got wild
Cory and wild Corey Hamilton technical
side and we got bud Galloway and Bud
Galloway is also another technician and
he's been out of town and he also
sometimes does a little bit of drinking
but wild Cory got a [ __ ] you know he
got that action in his [ __ ] Jax and
you know he got the you know he got that
you know he got a look he coming in like
he [ __ ] hung out in a thunderstorm
too much and caught off he didn't catch
lightning directly but he was sure as
[ __ ] was standing next to something that
got hit by it he's got that in him but
Chris Perez the beautiful Latino
gentleman he's the one who puts all
these calls in and and so here we go
there's another one that came in and
this is from Andrew who called back here
we go it's Andrew from PGI prints were
out in Canada again I didn't mention
that there's love there like I may not
be attracted to her but I deeply love
her and we have three beautiful children
whom I also deeply love so I definitely
don't just want to scrap it but I do
need to figure out how to make it work
mm-hmm well that's good that's good
added information and thank you for
calling out about that and I think you
got some good you know some unique calls
that have come in man and I'm glad that
you brought this up because this is a
[ __ ] real [ __ ] you know there's I
remember seeing a do one time is do just
when I was young dropped his wife off in
our neighborhood man and that was it
Dave this lady Terry boy
live us for about nine years I remember
seeing that dude leave boy that was it
[ __ ] I remember she got out and they
were arguing to something and I went
over there to look at the car because
the car was kind of nice it was like a
nova Chevy Nova and I like Dennis a fine
[ __ ] car boy you know and I had
bumper stickers and [ __ ] on it you know
what I'm saying [ __ ] that made it
[ __ ] tight and and they're [ __ ]
sitting there fighting man I'm looking
around in the windows and [ __ ] and then
he left
I remember even waving I thought I
didn't know who they were man I waved at
him and then Terry lived in our
neighborhood for about nine years but
her husband dropped her the [ __ ] off and
it was interesting as I had you know I
didn't ever have any feelings for her
nothing but I did you know I saw some of
her struggles and saw what was going on
and she would kind of you know there
were times where she went through bouts
where she was you know you know we go
over there sometime and we got innocent
when peeping tom was popular just before
everybody had cable when you just go get
you a little ladder you know or rent a
ladder and go watch people in the
neighborhood [ __ ] live their lives
sometimes it would be sex and those it'd
be people you know beating each other
with [ __ ] or I don't know what it would
be doing but um we should go peeping tom
at her house a little bit and it got
pretty interesting seeing a single lady
out there and them dating streets you
know in the early 90s crazy Goa all
right man uh let's hear a little more
this is this is another call that we got
right here and that's it that's all the
calls that we got Andrew they came in on
that top so I appreciate you calling in
and letting us kick it around a little
bit and it's you said that you go onto
that pornography as an outlet and that's
the date that now that's a separate
thing because then you have this whole
magnet of pornography that's attracting
you you know and that stuff gets wild
people you know catching uh you know I
seen a woman catch a ground-rule double
in her vagina on one of those you know
Vietnamese sites
and it's I mean damn boy this this lady
had a [ __ ] Ozzie Smith down there
tween her legs you know so you got to be
careful out there because you can get
addicted to that and they'll use
trickery like that to wrap you in a
pornography oh you love sports
okay we'll hear some lady catching a
[ __ ] foul ball in her ass and next
thing you know you think you're watching
baseball and next thing you know you
jerked off and you passed out and you
passed out in the family chair you
passed out on the couch are you don't
spray it out and passed out on the on a
glass coffee table and your nephew comes
in here and find you you know and that's
that and that then you're doing
something else because then you're
heading down that way and and I've had
and I have had I have struggled out in
MJ streets I've struggled in them jerks
in the thing I was thinking I was even
thinking about this today and we even
talked about a fighter and the kid that
I noticed when masturbation got out of
hand for daddy was when it wasn't even
about I wasn't even feeling that much
joy from catching that Newt you know
from [ __ ] you know cuz you you know
you pleasing him pleasing and pleasing
and then you catch that yeah you know
that Newt Gingrich boy
and I wasn't even feeling joy from
catching that Newt all I was feeling was
I was feeling like I had serviced a
habit you know what I'm saying like in
the beginning when I would jerk off or
masturbate I would feel uh uh you know
like a joy like oh yeah I'm all Randy
gent but then I noticed over time it
would feel like oh it was almost like if
you smoked a cigarette it was like oh it
just it fed the habit and what you
weren't getting anything out of the
action really any more you're getting a
little something but a higher percentage
of what you were getting was just
feeding the habit and for me that's when
I notice that not watching how much I
entertained the idea of pornography is
dangerous here we got a call right here
that came in and
from Michael here we go vo this is a
Michael from Tacoma Washington
Oh Tacoma and I'll be up there like I
mentioned earlier and that is March 15th
and 16th and the 17th I'll be in Spokane
let's hear more from you mr. Michael so
you're always talking about
self-pleasure and quitting masturbating
and all that and it got me to thinking
the the best of the worst orgasm I ever
had in regard to a self pleasure so you
know I started doing it when I was
around ten or eleven years old
oh man and it's crazy now cuz here you
know what's weird now is Michael tells
me that and now I'm picturing in my mind
a young boy now what the [ __ ] is going
on so does that mean I'm a bad person is
Michael a bad person or we just sharing
a story on word gold right and I thought
I was being slick by taking a shower so
I would take about three or four showers
a day oh yeah boy did I route there was
probably about seven months so I didn't
take a bath towel off my body why oh
they're [ __ ] young gunan dude then it
was fun jerking off when you were young
man how much [ __ ] fun was it you got
home from school people like what are
you gonna do oh nothing what are you
gonna do oh nothing
alright bro talk to you later then
everybody ran in their house and jerked
off dude
or sometime depending on the weather you
might you guys might [ __ ] jerk-off
out in the woods you know that was fun
man that was you being young and that
was when it was an adventure let's hear
more I'm curious now so there's one time
my dad he needed help moving a couch
because he just got a new couch so I'm
like hey Dad you know before I move this
couch let me take a quick shower so I
can get myself right and I mean and I
thought I was being slick obviously I
wasn't even what the [ __ ] I was doing
damn Dana that's an early warning sign
if you got a jerk off or you can even
adjust furniture it's gonna be a long
life because you know the average person
moves about probably about seven times
in their life that's your Mort
so I go to the bathroom I turn the
shower on and I'm sitting crisscross
applesauce on the floor and just kind of
do a little bit of sensual stuff with
myself you know so as I'm getting closer
I kind of stand up and get you this
thing so
kind of sprout and to think you know boy
that's that Oh that'll sink Jack huh
a real man goes over to the toilet and
tries to fire it all into the bowl and
you know that here we go Michael taking
the easy way out by the sink onward I
think you know no muss no fuss
all of a sudden my dad opens the door
and I could have sworn I locked that
damn door Oh cuz sometime you're
bringing your spine is so lit up on the
potential of jerkin that you [ __ ]
forgot to click that lock that scares me
so bad I just start spraying all over
the place all over the sink and all over
myself and the worst part is it felt
good too so it was the best I've ever
had and I think kind of chasing I've had
it ever since
damn dude so you probably wearing your
dad's shirt sometimes in his jerking off
to try to get back to that vibe hmm man
I can sympathize one time you know I was
and I'm and I'm Hardy in the [ __ ] boy
you know I'm saying I'm coming in thick
Rick you know I'm saying I'm coming in
all sternum and nipples bruh you know
I'm coming in damn son if my if my dick
had a rib cage it would have about 70
ribs in it and sometimes you know I'd be
masturbating at home because it became
you know a popular activity and I
remember one time pleasure myself and
sitting on the bed kind of one I was
kind of sitting on the bed had one knee
on the floor lived like on the edge of
the bed kind of kind of kneeling down
you know and you know and just you know
hit myself with a couple of a and C
cords right the air on the wing and my
mother opened the door and I was pals
like what mom close the door
so she closes the door now I'm high I'm
high on that erection you know I'm high
on that sensuality I mean I don't know
if there was a bigger dopamine rush than
being 14 in jerking off
so I go right back into it dude you know
I'm put you know what I'm saying I'm
playing um every rose has its thorn on
that you know I'm saying I hit right
back to those CA d chords on my wing you
know the ones them pleasure chords the
ones that get you right to that to that
poison you know and um and my mother
opened the door right back up like four
seconds later maybe to set like like and
I'm still jerking off and I'm like what
the [ __ ] man and that just and you know
it you know and I do I love the fact
that I've asked my mother one time about
that does she remember and she said she
doesn't remember it
and I believe that she does but a you
know in the and the kind heart of a
mother she would never say that she does
and and I you know I'm grateful for that
because I don't have to I can remember
that but when she tells me that she
doesn't it makes it so that I don't have
to remember that every time you know in
those awkward moments I don't have to
that doesn't weigh as heavily on me and
that is uh that's one of the graces that
our mothers allow us a lot of times is
the things they choose to forget and
that that makes me even think more about
your wife Andrew I don't know her
and look I don't I'm not saying that I
haven't I mean I've stepped out on any
woman that I've had any relationship
I've ever been in and I've struggled in
someone to talk but it is amazing the
gift that women have to look past things
sometimes it's amazing women a woman
that really loves you and cares about
your well-being the ability they have to
look past and to forget things that they
could remember now also boy then [ __ ]
be remembrance [ __ ]
then [ __ ] be remembering [ __ ] maybe
mothers a lot of times will do it but
that's a grace that women have you know
and that really almost is a definition
for me a very specific example of a
grace that women possess and that
mothers possess is the grace to not
remember things about their sons or
their daughters that that they know it
doesn't do them any good to hold on to
because they know that it only hurts us
if they do now we got a great call that
came in and I also wish you the best of
luck Andrew I mean I you know and I'm
not trying to add no judgment from me
you know and I don't think from any but
I thought a lot of neat I thought this
is a [ __ ] an interesting man there's
a lot of interesting a lot of
interesting [ __ ] at that because some
people's killing their wives they got a
man out there Scott Peterson's he killed
four or five [ __ ] wives dude this
dude killed four or five [ __ ] wives
and they can't catch him so it's you
know long as you're not doing that at
least you're starting from so you you
know you starting from somewhere if
that's not your start answer then at
least you're in the running to be a good
husband to be a decent man it's never
too late to turn things around you can
learn from everything so just [ __ ]
stay in it man stay in it all right we
got this call right here and I've been
bragging about this when I haven't even
heard it yet but this call seems so
legit to me now a lot of porn stars have
died in this past year last year and it
happened towards the end of the year and
uh and it's sad when anybody leaves this
earth but this call came in right here
hey Theo this is JP from Alabama JP I
recognize that voice that's my boy right
there JP let's hear it calling you about
what may be one of the darkest arts
fiamma bottom I'm thirty-five year old
and I got about 23 years and the
masturbation game
okay so you've been out there a good bit
man you at least uh you at least a green
belt and you are 35 do you sound about
sixty but no disrespect son Albert and I
was calling you about dead porn stars
man had two of the greatest passed away
in late 2017 well now they've left
behind all this material and I feel like
a lot of people that are you know
scrolling through these porn sites and
stuff
they may not know these girls are dead
hmm what are your thoughts on our people
jerking it to dead porn stars
Wow if you didn't know what that is
that's my mind blowing up
that's that [ __ ] brain shrapnel
landing in your lemonade cuz JP from
hell out of hammer who just won that
natty and natty a champion champion that
may ship that natin yung hitting him and
nick saban I'll say this dude I don't
care who your team is if you don't like
Nick Saban then you just have an issue
with greatness because that man is
captivating and but and here's wild tell
you this really quickly why he is
because the pressure that mounts
I know easy I know he's got a million
5-star recruits I think that they should
put a a eight I think that they should
stop the amount of recruits you can have
that are of a certain ranking I think
you should only be allowed so many to
even the playing field is that a certain
point that conduit to the NFL just runs
right through Tuscaloosa and they need
to shut that down at a certain point or
narrow that so you could widen other
rivers and in turn I think give a lot of
those players a bigger field to shine on
because they'll be up against less
talented players therefore they're gonna
shine brighter but I'll say this
with every year that they win in the
five out of seven years that they win
championships or whatever it is five out
of nine the pressure mounts and that is
when greatness that is when you are at
that level where the WiiU that is when
you can then reach for greatness
or or or bubble up even to a higher
level is when the pressure continues to
mount and you continue to rise and that
is what I think is remarkable about Nick
Saban and I'll say that about Nick Saban
and Bill Belichick's he might be
cheating they might be doing different
things and shooting stuff and special
cameras you know and hiding you know DVR
and people's [ __ ] kneecaps and [ __ ]
but they continue to win they continue
to rise into Excel and and that's
remarkable about those guys but JP down
in Alabama hit us with that question and
it made me think a lot of people do not
know that they are masturbating sadly to
deceased porn stars and what do you
think about that what would the porn
stars think about that would they want
their work to still be out there for men
to pleasure themselves do you think that
is dirtier of men to be doing that you
know to be telling their own soil when
nothing can even grow in it anymore
it's a good question and that's one that
we're really gonna we're gonna get into
on on Sunday night's episode of this
past weekend I I have some friends that
are in the pornography business
associates wouldn't say close friends
but I have some people and I'm going to
talk to and I'll see if I can get them
to chime in on it maybe we'll get one or
two on a live call if we can for
Monday's episode and we'll get to the
bottom of this if you have some calls
about that you can hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I want to thank everybody who
called
I want to thank Brendan Schaub who hit
us up and had me in on fighter in the
kid today and chin you and MJ and also I
got a gift right here you know I'm
grateful I mentioned him a lot great
block pizzas our charter sponsor and
they came on this year and have been
last year and I've been so helpful in
support and also some leadership man
they got a they got a fellow over there
who who helps too he just helps me thank
some times and helps me get a better
overview of of just growing up sometimes
different stuff but anyhow I just want
to say he gave me a gift man
we met up and great I want to thank the
people of our great block pizza you know
and they gave me this gift right here
and so I'm going to open it right here
on air and if you're on audio you can't
see it if you're on youtubes you can see
it and this have green wrapping paper
inside of it and I like the color green
that boy gave me that hitter right there
oh and this is a Patagonia's and that's
patagonian that's a mountain range down
there and um I think that's Chile and
this thing's bright green Sun because
you know I've been hit by a Trans Am at
3 years old I got hit by a silver Trans
Am down there in Covington Louisiana and
maybe it wouldn't have happened if I'd
have had this song you know maybe this
is something nice to wear something safe
to wear but I'm happy to sport something
wild and I want to thank our people of
our great block pizza for give me that
green hitter and if you want that food
you want to get you fill yourself up and
you haven't tried it you're in Los
Angeles go to 1811 Pico Boulevard on
your way to the beach gray block pizza
get that hit as always you can grab
onward this past weekend t-shirts at
Theo von , slash store
I want to thank Joey Coco Diaz for give
me a call this week and inspire me you
know uh I want to just wish you good
luck out there Andrew I want to wish you
good luck man you know it's gonna be
hard to probably the because my problem
is I'll start something I won't be able
to continue it very well but I so if I
have a wish for you I just wish that
that doesn't happen to you that you are
able to to hold the line man
because you got sound like you got three
beautiful kids and you're a loving
father and sounds like you're a loving
husband because I've been at the bottom
of all this you just really care you
know you didn't call and say I'm out
there you know touching ladies [ __ ]
and stuff in a back seat you know I'm
out there buying a van and [ __ ] you
know meat and strippers and you know
install them [ __ ] toys and [ __ ] in
the back of the van you said this I'm in
a tough spot and I'm jerking out and I'm
catching seed out there outside of the
bedroom well that's okay that's okay man
but I wish you well bud thank you guys
for being here I'll see you guys on
Monday if you guys choose to show up if
you don't choose to show up I appreciate
showing up this time oh [ __ ] dude it's
okay man we got the playoffs coming up I
wish my Saints good luck Nick Swardson I
hope you catch a [ __ ] strong D boy in
the J son and the Jews all because him
Saints gonna go up there and do
something special with them Vikes
and we'll see it boy I remember the
first playoff game I ever saw was the
Saints first playoff game and they
played the Minnesota Vikings and my best
friend William Teague lived across the
street from me and his mother was a
beautiful woman and she still is a thing
and I went over there to watch that game
we were so excited I mean it was never
any more excitement I'd ever had in my
life and the Saints got beat I believe
41 to 10 and that's when I knew not the
devil Lert that the devil Lert you guys
be good man be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it I'm out of here
[Music]
Gang Gang who dead
celebrate
celebrate man
[Music]
be good to yourselves baby I bet you do
a pet you deserve offense